scammers use every means to find victims
that you can think of
people create kind of a relationship
with people sometimes they use
professional relationships sometimes
they use a romantic relationship
sometimes they just use people's
interest in making money they have all
kinds of tactics I think what train is a
new type of scam that involves
cryptocurrency and uses this rather
colorful metaphor pigs and and
butchering so in this case pigs means a
victim a person who is tricked into
being sort of fattened up you're enticed
to spending more and more and more and
more money you're getting fattened up
and then at some point you're butchered
or slaughtered which means sort of to
mix metaphors a little bit the rug is
pulled out from under you you come to a
point where you find out that it's a
scam and the scammer kind of runs away
with all your money
in the case of the story that I've just
published for Forbes this involves a
victim named Psy he was approached kind
of out of the blue from a text message
that he got from a person who called
herself Jessica she claimed that they
were old work colleagues and they
started a conversation that way Psy was
at a very emotionally vulnerable point
in his life
[Music]
his father was in the last stages of his
life where finances were on his mind
knowing that he would have to provide
financially for medical care and you
know over the period of a couple of
weeks their conversations started moving
from kind of Chit Chat to becoming more
frequent and to becoming more intense
and revolving around discussions of
finance and specifically around
cryptocurrency and she told him that she
had made boatloads of cash through you
know supposed Insider information that
she was receiving from an uncle in Hong
Kong and that she could teach him also
how to make the same amount of money
over the period of several weeks she had
him initially transfer money to
crypto.com he put in at first uh ten
thousand dollars and then he used that
money to buy at first ethereum and later
tether which he then used to transfer to
an app that he downloaded off the Apple
App Store called metatrader a metatrader
is a trading app that allows brokerages
to kind of plug in to their trading
interface SCI didn't totally follow what
was happening in metatrader it looks
just like any kind of normal trading
interface that one would use that's
available in the Google Play Store it's
available on the Apple App Store it's an
app that has a lot of good ratings and
that was one of the things that made Psy
think that this whole operation was
legitimate he believed that his
investment was making money
foreign
they're showing him what he wants to see
they're showing him what he believes to
be prophets Jessica would tell him kind
of out of nowhere to click buy up or
down in the app he didn't fully
understand what that meant but what he
did know was that each time he followed
her instructions almost always it would
show that his you know purported
Investments would end higher if you're
trading on a legitimate trading
interface right you see the profits and
losses over time and this is exactly
what he saw and at every single step of
the way he would send screenshots to
Jessica showing her that he was
following her directions showing her
that he actually was you know wiring
money to crypto.com and then
transferring it to metatrader probably
using a particular plugin called virtual
dealer they're able to present false
information and show returns that do not
exist they're basically just creating an
elaborate deception to make him believe
that he can make his money during the
course of this scam his father actually
passed away and that was I think around
the time when Jessica decided to go for
the butchering this so-called big Market
came just after Psy's father passed away
foreign
[Music]
on the one hand it's easy to blame
people and say well you know you should
have known better but I think after
talking to Psy for such a long time and
reading through this transcript really
any one of us could be manipulated I
think scammers are really good at
exploiting those weaknesses I can just
imagine being in a situation where
you've experienced a really traumatic
loss in your life and and here's a
person who wants to supposedly listen to
you and wants to hear you and supposedly
wants to help you experts believe that
the scale of these scams is in the
billions of dollars annually and it's
quite frightening because there have
been relatively few documented cases of
victims being able to get their money
back the scammers are believed to be
people largely if not entirely in
Southeast Asia primarily operating out
of Cambodia Myanmar and Laos the people
that are doing the scams in many
instances according to reporting that
I've done and research that's being done
by the global anti-scam organization are
people who themselves shockingly are
victims also oftentimes these are people
Chinese speaking or English-speaking who
are lured from countries like Malaysia
Philippines Thailand Taiwan through the
prospect of a job app they see a job ad
people are looking for work people have
been you know lost work during the
pandemic and see an opportunity come to
Cambodia to come to Myanmar to come to
Laos to work maybe in a casino to work
in a call center something like that and
in many many instances people find that
when they get there their passports are
seized their phones are seized and
they're basically put to work scamming
people this type of scam originated
largely among chinese-speaking
communities and has since expanded to
English-speaking communities as well
they are told to scam people and this is
a way to just extract money from people
who live in the United States and in
countries around the world so you know
American law enforcement and I'm sure
law enforcement agencies around the
world are trying to work as hard as they
can to put a stop to this but as of now
it seems that the scammers have the
upper hand